I think everybody lies for themselves
being a dick about it I know I'm sitting
in a room full of number twos threes and
fours there's so many people in this
room that are like gonna be dot like
could be dominant number two threes and
fours and I'm pissed that the narrative
now is that you need to be a number one
and have your company because a lot of
people gonna lose or leave money on the
table because that's just a narrative I
really do think you have to audit who
you actually are you can look at like
how people roll and like it's great to
admire and things of that nature but
it's so damn important you need to bet
on your strengths and don't give a [ __ ]
about what you suck at way too many
people this room we're gonna spend the
next 3040 years of their lives trying to
check the boxes other things that
they're not as good at and that you're
gonna waste a fuckload of time and lose
to stick to like your DNA because the
truth is if you want to be an anomaly
you've got to act like one you know like
what so that's it that's what I got so
thanks for having me